en el último vídeo vimos que china ha
incrementado su reserva de dinero m1 de
noviembre de 2009 a noviembre de 2010
más o menos por 700.000 millones de
dólares verdad
así que lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es comparar eso con el incremento
en activos en el extranjero así que nos
movemos acá arriba de nuevo toda esta
información es directa del sitio web del
banco popular de china que está aquí
está la url justo aquí y puedes obtener
muchísimos años' toneladas de
información así que esta tabla nos dice
los activos en el extranjero ahora solo
quiero centrarme en los activos en el
extranjero porque cuando imprimen su
moneda y con su dinero impreso van a
comprar dólares con esos dólares
podríamos comprar o podrían guardarlos
igual como dólares o podrían comprar
bonos de tesorería o podrían ir a no sé
muchos lado
de hecho los bienes son la mejor medida
de lo que están guardando eso está
denominado en otras monedas así que
vamos a mirar su crecimiento de
noviembre de 2009 a noviembre de 2010
por esto es que elegí noviembre porque
no tenemos diciembre de 2010 en esta
tabla así que los activos en el
extranjero otra vez esto está en cientos
de millones de yuan activos en el
extranjero son 183 mil 651 y está en
cientos de millones de yuan y nos vamos
rápidamente a noviembre de 2010 es 212
mil 733
así que una vez más vamos a poner esto
en términos que hagan un poquito más de
sentido al menos para alguien que está
acostumbrado a los dólares así que una
aproximación para eeuu
los cambios de joana dólares en los
últimos años sean de 6.58 pero bueno
aquí tenemos un incremento de 700 mil
millones en fin terminamos con 212 mil
733 cientos de millones de yuans en el
en activos en el extranjero
ok menos 183 mil 651 que es la
diferencia ok
ahí está y esto está en cientos de
millones de johann así que vamos a
multiplicar esto por 100 y esto nos dará
en millones de yuans y ahora dividimos
esto por 1000 que nos dará miles de
millones de jong que de hecho está cerca
está cerca de los 2900 miles de yuanes
miles de millones de yuan verdad que si
queremos convertirlo en dólares puedo
hacerlo con 6.58 dejen de usar 6.58 así
que si divido esto por 6.58 para
ponerlo en millones miles de millones de
dólares aquí tenemos un incremento de
440 mil millones en activos en el
extranjero denominados en dólares más o
menos así que pensemos en ello pensemos
sobre esto el m1 de noviembre de 2009 a
noviembre de 2010 desde noviembre de
2009 a noviembre noviembre perdón de
m1 estaba aproximadamente en 700 mil
millones de dólares
ok setecientos mil millones de dólares y
los activos en el extranjero estaban
aproximadamente cuál es el número que
había que que había escrito
aproximadamente 440 mil millones y así
que el desarrollo de la base monetaria
de su base m1 era para salir a comprar
activos extranjeros a lo largo de 2010 y
los balances realmente como que
sostienen el crecimiento de la economía
china actual con la mayoría de esto es
para salir y comprar activos extranjeros
en otras monedas y así ayudar a mantener
donde evaluado reportando de lacan
academy para la cnc